we just thought this was interesting and
worth addressing so Candace Owens raised
a pretty relevant question the other day
on social media and got a huge response
she wrote this serious question from it
do you think that the botox filler fake
lips look attractive
now that's a real that's a real question
because all of a sudden everybody in
power has fake faces Nancy pulse looks
like Michael Jackson not being mean but
it's true the governor of Michigan
Gretchen Whitmer clearly keeping Botox
stock afloat single-handedly and then
manner in on it too what part of Joe
Biden is still real none Jeff Bezos
completely transformed by this stuff so
we thought we would ask Candace Owens
like what's going on here is this a sign
of something deeper a deeper fakeness
infecting our leadership class Canada so
this is of course the host of the
Canada's own show we're happy to have
her now okay so Candace what I mean you
addressed the the most sensitive topics
in American life you know race religion
like you're not afraid of anything but
this got a huge response why
oh man Botox gate I was very surprised I
landed myself in a puddle of uh-oh and
I'm laughing out loud now because I can
never look at that photo of Nancy
Nancy's eyebrows and not chuckle to
myself but yeah I've been very curious
and I cover this on my podcast all the
time talking about our psychological
immune system meaning that we're
constantly looking at all these digital
toxins we scroll through our phones on
social media and then we suddenly start
emulating the behavior that we see you
know case in point wear a mask save
lives now people are suddenly masking
their children and won't go outside or
an element of that is that you go on
social media and everybody's starting to
look the same it's like Avatar it's very
bizarre and I'm not against people that
want to get BOTOX and nip and Tuck I
don't personally do it but I was curious
if men found this new face that everyone
has decided upon to be attractive and
boy was I met with so much heat from
women I have a close friend of mine who
gets Botox she said Candace you're
launching a war on us white women how
dare you this is what we have to do I
realize that some topics Tucker aren't
back too sensitive and I would like to
apologize to all of my fans and
listeners and I will leave your Botox
and your filler alone but we should
investigate what is happening to Nancy's
eyebrows well I agree with that but in
and everyone is trying to look the same
and that's a really insightful
observation which never occurred to me
but men I mean I don't want to be judgy
everyone does his own thing or whatever
but it's a little bit there's something
a little bit
awful about that is there not well I'll
tell you what's awful about it the first
thing is that men age like fine wine Men
actually get better as they age it's
just a fact a man at 20 is not going to
look as good as a man at 45 so it's
really bizarre that they're trying to
hold on to their youth when women prefer
older guy when they start to get gray
hair and things of that nature and yet
they too are being impacted by this
psychological immune system on Instagram
and everybody's orange look the same you
know it's very hard to tell the
difference between a trans man and a
woman that's been getting a lot of work
and this is just where we're at today
and we should I wanted to open the
conversation and say hey it's possible
to just like your face and to age
gracefully and I learned that people are
not ready yet to have that conversation
I agree I never got any plastic surgery
until I turned 65 and then I was like
you know I have no choice
just kidding uh cancer it's great to see
you tonight thank you for that
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight